ça va ouais il m'est arrivé un truc trop
bar en bar raconte je joue avec mon kit
de petit chimiste et en mettant les
éprouvettes dans l'eau pour les rincer
ça s'est mis à mousser c'était de la
bière attends tu veux dire que tu as
découvert la formule pour transformer
l'eau en bière tu vas devenir des choix
ben non j'ai tout jeté pourquoi t'as
fait ça y est c'est fabriquer la pâte à
modeler j'ai raté ça m'a énervé dommage
quand même est-ce que vous connaissez
point commun entre la tarte tatin et le
viagra
oui ok non alors pour les autres est ce
que vous connaissez
l'autre point commun entre la tarte
tatin et le viagra et bah ils ont été
tous les deux découvert par hasard alors
pour la tarte
il ya plusieurs versions mais bon c'est
pas le sujet toute façon a priori c'est
lié à une erreur ou une maladresse de
deux aubergiste de lamotte beuvron
les soeurs tatin et on doit le viagra à
une boulette de jean kévin viagra aux
questions c'est faux on doit le viagra à
ce qu'on appelle la sérendipité
c'est à dire tout simplement l'art de
faire une découverte scientifique parade
bon allez je vous raconte le viagra
en 1991 un labo lance une étude clinique
sur une molécule le citrate de
sildénafil qu'ils ont mis au point pour
traiter un certain type de maladies
cardiaques qu'on appelle l'angor ou
encore angine de poitrine comme souvent
dans ces cas là on donne à un groupe de
patients le médicament et aux autres un
placebo
assez vite on se rend compte que ça
marche pas très bien enfin ça marche pas
très bien sur le quai en tout cas
l'étude est arrêté et au moment de
rendre les comprimés il ya un certain
nombre de patients qui traîne un peu les
pieds l'histoire en sera resté là si
personne n'avait cherché à comprendre
pourquoi et il s'est avéré que les
petits malins avaient remarqué que le
viagra ne faisait pas grand chose à leur
coeur c'est vrai mais qu'il avait un
effet bénéfique sur un autre organe
quelques ajustements dans le médicament
et cette année plus tard le viagra
obtient son autorisation de mise sur le
marché en 1998 mais pas pour le club
pour le labo c'est le jackpot avec
plusieurs milliards de dollars de ventes
pas mal pour un essai raté coll mais
bien avant ça il y avait déjà eu les
anti vieux alors oui c'est un autre
registre mais bon c'est quand même utile
les antibiotiques aussi bon en réalité
c'est pas vraiment les antibiotiques
pour été découvert par hasard c'est la
pénicilline et tout le monde est à peu
près d'accord pour dire que c'est la
grande date dans l'histoire des antibios
et donc c'est arrivé par hasard ça se
passe en 1928 quand un bactériologiste
écossais alexander fleming reprend le
boulot après quelques vacances quand il
arrive dans son labo y constate que les
petites boîtes dans lesquelles il
faisait pousser des staphylocoques
je sais des bactéries elles sont pleines
de moisissures la loose irréaliste que
ces boîtes ont été contaminés par celle
d'un de ses collègues il est râpeux
vénère et il s'apprête à tout jeter
quand soudain il se rend compte que le
penicillium not a top c'est le nom de la
moisissure a détruit les staphylocoques
alors en vrai il y avait un français qui
avait déjà bossé sur le même sujet 30
ans plus tôt mais tout le monde s'en
foutait donc alors ceci dit les travaux
de fleming tout le monde s'en foutait
aussi parce que c'est que dix ans plus
tard qu'ils ont été repris par deux
autres scientifiques et que la
pénicilline a été fabriquée de manière
industriel happy end fleming il aura
quand même le prix nobel de médecine en
même temps que les deux autres en 1945
la chimiothérapie
alors là c'est un peu particulier parce
que la découverte a pas été fait pendant
des recherches scientifiques va bon je
vous explique pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale
en 1943 les allemands bombardent le port
de bari en italie et il se trouve qu'un
des bateaux touché contient 60 dote
d'une arme chimique bien connu le gaz
moutarde
sauf que personne n'est au courant mais
comme le nombre de morts et de malades
augmente de jour en jour un médecin le
docteur alexander est appelé pour mener
l enquête il finit par découvrir deux
choses 1
les victimes ont été exposées au gaz
moutarde donc et 2 les cellules
présentes dans leur sens et notamment
leurs globules blancs sont anormalement
bas des pharmacologues de l'université
de yale se penche sur la question et
découvre que les moutards d'azoté
présente dans le gaz empêche la
multiplication des cellules qui se
divisent rapidement donc de certaines
cellules saines comme celle du sang ou
celle des racines capillaire par exemple
mais aussi des cellules cancéreuses
la chimiothérapie anticancéreuse
l'anesthésique
alors depuis toujours les médecins et
surtout les chirurgiens vont essayer de
rendre leur boulot un peu moins pénible
pour leurs patients en utilisant des
techniques pour calmer la douleur plus
ou moins artisanal et plus ou moins
efficaces mais il ya une date importante
dans l'histoire de l'anesthésiste et
1844 à cette époque garner qsi colton
qui a un ancien étudiant en médecine et
apprentis chimistes il fait le tour des
états unis pour présenter des shows avec
le gaz hilarant qui l'a mis au point un
jour dans le connecticut à volontaires
choisis dans le public force un peu la
dose et se blesse gravement à une jambe
mais grâce au gaz
il ne ressent aucune douleur et il se
trouve que dans le public et un dentiste
du coin qui s'appelle aura swayze qui
flairent le bon coup et qui veut tester
le gaz pour faire des extractions
dentaires
colton accepte et élu fils même un coup
de main et ça marche
du coup l'inventeur peaufine sa
trouvaille
et elle est toujours utilisé aujourd'hui
sous le nom de protoxyde d'azoté
alors pour être tout à fait juste pour
quand même glisser un petit mot sur cros
forte longue qui est un chirurgien qui
aurait lui inventer l'anesthésié à
lesterps deux ans plus tôt mais comme il
en a parlé à personne
bah c'est un autre qui a récupéré ses
lauriers un petit peu plus tard être
c'est être perçue par les médicaments
qui change de job là on change un peu de
style c'est pas tellement des
médicaments qu'on a découvert par hasard
c'est plutôt des médicaments dont on a
découvert qu'ils marchaient pas mais qui
pouvait avoir une autre utilité on va
parler de l'aspartame
par exemple vous connaissez la spartan à
la base c'était censé être un médicament
pour soigner les ulcères et pendant les
recherches il ya un chimiste qui
s'appelle james clac heures qui veut
tourner une page
pour ça il se lèchent le doigt et il
découvre que les cristaux qui est là
dessus sont très sucré bon alors à la
base se lécher les doigts pour tourner
une page moi perso je trouve ça
dégueulasse faire ça dans un labo de
chimie quant à des cristaux sur les
doigts faut vraiment être bref c'est pas
le débat résultat à l'aspartame a jamais
soigné aucun ulcère mais on a fini par
en foot partout comme édulcorant
mais ce n'était pas l'idée du siècle
mais pas le débat nous on a aussi le
primpéran alors c'est un neuroleptique
c'est-à-dire un médicament de la famille
de ceux qui sont utilisés
les troubles psychotiques mais qui est
employé pour calmer les nausées et les
vomissements
là encore ça a posé quelques soucis donc
l' agence européenne du médicament à
calmer un petit peu le jeu surtout chez
les enfants pour limiter les effets
secondaires dans un registre un petit
peu plus léger on peut aussi parler du
pepsi cola qui au départ a été mis au
point pour soigner des troubles
digestifs qu'on appelle la dyspepsie
d'où le nom ou de jager majster qui
était censé au départ être un remède
contre la toux et les troubles digestifs
et qui est devenu un remède contre la
dignité alors fun fact jager majster ça
veut dire mettre chasseurs faut pas
s'étonner qu'ils confondent essangui
avec des vtt après des exemples de
médicaments ou de traitements divers qui
ont été découverts par hasard il y en a
plein d'autres
alors vous allez me dire super donc les
chercheurs c'est au pire des branleurs
au mieux des mecs qui ont la chance
alors non évidemment parce que d'abord
sur la somme de découvertes qui ont été
faites ça reste des exceptions et puis
surtout parce que pour que ça donne une
découverte
il faut être capable de réagir quand il
ya un résultat inattendu et de suivre
une piste qu'on n'avait pas forcément
prévu cuivre départ
d'ailleurs louis pasteur en personne
aurait dit à ce sujet lazare ne favorise
que les esprits préparés wesh voit la
dtcc fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Musique]